[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Hello.
I'm Jeffrey van Gogh.
I am a tech lead
on Android Studio.
And I'm there responsible
for programming languages
and compilers.
HADI HARIRI: And I'm
Hadi, developer advocate
at JetBrains.
[CHEERING]
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: So
it's been two years
since Google announced
Kotlin support for Android.
And yesterday we announced that
Google is going Kotlin-first.
So we figured we give you
some background on this.
And so, of course, we
didn't start two years ago.
We took quite some
time to get things
ready for Kotlin on Android.
And we decided about
3, 3 and 1/2 years ago,
there was a bunch of us
language geeks at Google--
[INAUDIBLE] me-- starting to
play with Kotlin, and like,
hey, this is
actually quite nice.
And of course, Android
Studio is based on IntelliJ.
And IntelliJ started using
Kotlin in its old code base.
So we started to see
more and more Kotlin
being used in Android Studio.
And at the same
time, we were getting
a lot of customer feedback
from our Customer Advisory
Board, surveys, and
ad hoc discussions
at conferences like these
that people really like Kotlin
and they really would
like Google to support it,
because their companies would
not adopt Kotlin otherwise.
Of course, taking on a
new language like that
is a big task.
So we had to convince our
directors that this was
something worth investing in.
The best way we
found to do this was
to just get our
directors to code
for a couple days in Kotlin.
And after that, they were sold.
So a couple months before I/O
2017, we decided to go for it,
and this meant so many
meetings to set this all up.
If you think, as a
tech lead or manager,
you don't have enough
time for coding anymore,
try setting up a foundation.
So we got this all ready one
day before Google I/O 2017.
There was this big thread
on Android Dev subreddit
how Google is never
going to embrace Kotlin.
Of course, we knew what
was going to happen,
but it was so hard to
not reply to that thread.
So yeah, two years
ago, Steph was onstage
announcing Kotlin support.
I think it was the loudest
applause of the developer
keynote.
It was amazing.
Of course, we all knew at
both JetBrains and Google
that that meant that
we had a lot of work
ahead of us to make sure
that Kotlin worked well
for Android and in general.
And so today, we
want to show some
of the work we have done
over the last two years.
Hadi will talk
about what happened
to Kotlin in the last years,
and then I'll take it back,
and I'll talk about what
we did on the Android side.
HADI HARIRI: Thank you.
So to start, I want
to just mention
about the Kotlin
Foundation, which,
if you remember when Google
announced official support two
years ago for Kotlin, we
also briefly mentioned
that we'll be forming a
foundation, which was created
by JetBrains and Google to
protect, promote, and advance
the language Kotlin.
The foundation is governed by
a board of directors, which
are two representatives of
JetBrains, two of Google,
and one independent member.
And to give you a
little bit of a idea
on what the scope of the
foundation is, one of the jobs
is to appoint a language lead
designer, which currently,
of course, is Andrey
Breslav, and there's
a Language Committee that
controls breaking changes.
And it's very important
here to understand that this
is limited in terms of scope.
So it is only about
breaking changes.
Kotlin continues to be developed
as it is now in the open,
on GitHub.
We still have the KEEP,
which is the Kotlin Evolution
Enhancement Process.
But the Language Committee
is mostly around controlling
the breaking changes that
might happen into the language.
And also, there's a
trademark subcommittee
that is about protecting
the trademark of Kotlin,
and working with the community
to help promote Kotlin and use
Kotlin in a fair way.
And if you want to find out
more about the foundation,
you can go to the
KotlinLang website,
where you'll have more
information as well as details
about how you can use Kotlin
and trademarks, et cetera.
And with that, let's
switch over to the demo.
And I'm going to show you
some things with the language.
This is where I'm using
someone else's machine.
Let's see how this goes.
I think the ID's correct.
Yes.
So I'll show you some
things around the language.
So probably the most
fundamental, most important
thing that we have done,
which has taken a very, very
long time, if you're familiar
with writing a Kotlin
application, you have
your main entry point.
So we've actually now made that
so you don't have parameters.
So that's it.
Thank you.
Jeffrey, do you want to-- oh.
[LAUGHTER]
We took two years.
No.
So we'll start with some
of the small things we've
done with the language itself.
So for instance,
one of the things
with the when statements
is that often you
have to capture the
value of a variable,
and then you have to
examine that variable,
and you're only using
that inside your actual
when statement.
So we've made this
a little bit nicer
in that you can essentially
declare the variable inside the
when statement itself.
So you don't have to have it
reference outside of the scope.
And this gives you the
semanticness in your language,
so that people understand
that this is actually limited
to just the conditional.
But let's talk about
a little bit more
some nice features
that we've introduced.
Not that those weren't nice.
I'm just saying nicer features
that we've introduced.
So let's say that I have,
for instance, an application,
and I want to create a class.
And I'm going to
create my class,
and it's going to be
called the MicroserviceAPI.
So I can create an instance
of my MicroserviceAPI,
and I'll say MicroserviceAPI.
There we go.
Now, the thing is, I don't know
if this microservice thing is
going to last.
It might just be a fad.
So what I want to
do is tell people
that are using this
that this is kind
of like an experimental feature.
So what we can do
is we can actually
create an annotation class.
And I can say, for
example, this is a new API
and then annotate
that annotation class
with this other class
called Experimental.
And now I can use that new
Experimental annotation
that I have created on anything
that I consider experimental
in my API.
So I could add
this new API here.
And as soon as I do that,
notice that this is going red.
So it's giving me
a compiler error.
It's saying that
you cannot use this,
because this is an
experimental feature.
If we hover over it, it's
saying that it's experimental.
And in fact, we can change that.
We can say that instead
of it being an error,
we can actually define
it as the warning.
So here it could be a warning,
and it's just now going
to show up as a warning.
So in order to use
this, the developer
has to essentially opt
in to this feature.
So what I could do
is hit Alt-Enter,
and now that adds the new
API to my function call.
So anywhere where
I'm using this,
it is saying that this is
an experimental feature.
This gives people
idea into you can now
create APIs that could be
experimental and kind of like,
I'm not going to
guarantee anything.
If tomorrow we want to
change something, it's OK.
You had the warning.
You did hit Alt-Enter.
I saw you hit Alt-Enter.
It's OK.
It's your own fault.
And one of the things that
we've actually done with this
is we've introduced this
concept of contracts.
So if you're familiar with
a little bit code contracts,
we've introduced this as a
experimental feature in Kotlin
as well.
So let's say that I have
some function that is
like, for example, printLength.
And this is going to take
a string that is nullable,
and then it's going to
do if string is not-null,
I'm going to do println length.
Now, this works, and
it's done a smart cast
to a string, a
not-nullable string,
because it detects
that I've already
found out that this
is not-nullable,
so I can do this smart cast.
But if I were to take this,
and instead of doing not-null,
I do something like notNull,
and I go ahead and create
my function, so let's say
I create my function that
is a String and notNull, that's
going to return a Boolean.
And then I say return
this is not-null.
You see that it doesn't
have that effect,
because the compiler doesn't
guarantee that that is actually
not-nullable.
So it would really nice to
kind of tell the compiler
that this function complies
with a certain contract.
And you can do this
in Kotlin by defining,
using the contract lambda,
the contract function, which
is contract.
And I can say that
that's imported.
And I can say
returns, true, implies
that this@notNull is not-null.
Now, this gives an error.
Ignore it.
No, I'm joking.
The reason that
this gives an error
is because this, as I mentioned,
is an experimental feature.
And there's two ways--
I showed you the first one--
you could add the annotation.
But if you add the annotation,
that doesn't propagate.
So if something
is using that API,
that also has to
add the annotation.
You can add the
propagating annotation
to this, which is
this format, and now I
don't have to do that.
And as soon as I add that
notice, that this now
automatically again casts to
a string that is not-nullable.
So this allows you to actually
create contracts and say
that your arguments
to your function
match certain conditions.
And that basically
is guaranteeing
you a certain level
of code correctness
in your actual code.
So what else have
we been working on?
Well, we've done this thing
called serialization, which
is a serialization library,
which is multiplatform
and that is targeting JVM,
JavaScript, Kotlin/Native, iOS,
macOS, Linux, Windows, Embedded.
I think I mentioned
everything under the sun.
And this is a
multiplatform library
that doesn't require
any kind of reflection,
and it's part of
some of the offerings
that we're doing as part of
the language and the ecosystem
around it.
So here you can see that I have
a class, a typical data class,
and I have added this
serializable annotation to it,
which is part of the Kotlin
serialization library,
and then I have a customer and
I have a list of customers.
So I could do
something like println.
And then here I'm going to
do Json.stringify, Customer,
and indicate the serializer
I want to use, and then
pass in the actual customer.
And I could do exactly the same
thing for a list of customers.
So I could do list here and then
pass in the list of customers.
And if I were to run this, what
this is basically going to do
is output that
data class in JSON.
And we have support for JSON.
We have support for Protobuf.
And other things
are in the works.
And we can obviously
do the reverse as well.
So I could say,
for example, let's
say that I have some JSON here.
So let's go ahead
and create some JSON.
So we'll do id equals 1,
and then name equals Me,
and then email
equals you@me.com.
I'm so creative.
And now I can do println,
and in this case,
I'm going to do Json.parse,
passing again the serializer,
and then the actual JSON
that I want to pass in.
And what this will do
is essentially create
the actual data class
object for me in reverse.
And you can see that it
also has support for--
it creates the data
object for me in reverse.
What did I do?
Email, name, email.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HADI HARIRI: Field
source is required?
No, it's not.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HADI HARIRI: No.
That should actually-- right.
Anyway, so that was working.
[LAUGHTER]
That's Jeffrey.
He did something.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Uh-huh.
[APPLAUSE]
HADI HARIRI: I really
like when people clap.
So I don't know what's
happening there.
But that's the good
thing about live demos.
I want to make sure that
something goes wrong.
I actually did that on purpose.
So I've done that
as an exercise,
so that later you come
to me in our office hours
and you tell me what's
wrong with that.
Let's move on.
The next thing I
want to show you
is a quick overview also on
terms of annotation classes.
Here, we've added some
additional things for support
for enums.
For example, I can get the
have enums in my annotation.
I can have nested annotations.
I can have properties as
part of my companion object.
So again, this gives
me more expressiveness
in when I'm using the
actual annotations.
Now there's one other thing
that we've been working on,
which you may have
heard about, which
is multiplatform programming.
And the idea behind
multiplatform programming,
which is a mouthful, is the
idea that right now Kotlin
allows you to target
different types of platforms.
So I can target the JVM.
I can target JavaScript.
I can target native, et cetera.
Now one of the great
things about this
is the ability to be
able to share code,
because there's a lot of code
that I want to end up sharing.
Right?
There's business logic, there's
validation logic, et cetera,
that I want to end up sharing.
So how do we kind of do this?
This is where we've introduced
the concept of multiplatform
programming.
And as a consequence
of that, you now
have the idea of having
this multiplatform project.
So you can see here that I've
got this project in my IDE
and I'm targeting different
kinds of platforms.
So I have macOS, I have
JVM, and I have JavaScript.
And then I have a
series of common code
which is called common.
And inside here
I have some code.
So here I have this
function called hello
that is saying hello
from platform.name.
And platform.name is
a property of object.
But the difference
is that this object
has this word in front of
it, which is called expect.
So what this is saying
is that this is some code
that I can reference
in my common code,
but the implementation is
not actually provided here.
The implementation is
going to be provided
on different types of
platforms in a different way,
because it can vary
based on the platform.
So you can see that
it's got this cute
little a in the corner here.
And if we hit Alt Enter, when
we say go to declaration,
it asks me which platform
declaration do I want to go to.
So if I say JVM, it will
take me to the JVM one.
If I go back and I say go to
actual declaration on macOS,
it will take me
to the macOS one.
Right?
So for different platforms I can
have different implementations,
and yet I can reference
that code in my common code
and use it as part of
my shared code base.
And a cool thing-- so
kind of like, think of it
as a little bit like
interfaces and then
the implementation
of those interfaces.
And the cool thing is that you
get the static compile time
checking, so to speak.
So if I were to comment
this out and I go back here,
you can see that it's
giving me an error,
saying that one of
the actual platforms
is missing an implementation.
So this is allowing
you to now create
multiplatform projects that
allow you to share common code
base and then have specific
implementations based
on the actual target a
little bit differently.
And that's part of the
multiplatform project
that we are offering
moving forward with Kotlin,
allowing you to,
for example, create
Android applications that share
common code base with Android,
iOS, et cetera.
And if we can switch
back to slides,
I will talk to you a
little bit about some
of the other things
that we've been bringing
to Kotlin the language.
We have more standard
library APIs.
We're still keeping the
API numbers of methods
calls kind of low, but we're
adding a lot more functionality
in that area.
Support for unsigned integers--
anybody?
No?
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
I just added that because
I know someone always
claps about that.
Obviously, we announced packet
KotlinConf in 2018 that's
Kotlin native has hit beta.
In terms of tooling, we've
provided improved performance
speed, parallel builds
for Gradle projects,
incremental annotation
processing with KAPT.
And shout out to Ivan
Garvrilovic from Google
for helping us with that.
New type inference
engine, which helps
in a lot of cases
in interoperability,
especially if you're
doing things around RX,
as well as making the
language a little bit more
concise when you're using
builders, et cetera.
And we've introduced this
progressive mode, which
is essentially allowing
you to try out Kotlin,
try out new features, even if
those features will actually
break some code.
So that's a flag
that you can now
enable with Kotlin to kind
of live a little bit more
on the edge.
And with that, I'll
hand it off to Jeffrey
that's going to show you some
other things that we've been
doing in Android specifically.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Thanks, Hadi.
I think there is one feature
that you forgot to demo.
HADI HARIRI: I have no idea
what you're talking about.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: It's OK.
I'll show it to my demo.
HADI HARIRI: You
probably broke it.
[LAUGHTER]
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: OK.
So let's take a look at what we
have done in the Android side
to support Kotlin.
So let's first
start with the OS.
Of course, the OS
works on byte code.
So there's not a lot we need
to do to support Kotlin.
But we did make sure
that we added correctness
and performance tests so that
we don't break Kotlin patterns.
We implemented a couple
of specific performance
optimizations based
on those tests,
specifically for
loop optimizations.
And then the big thing
we did on the OS side
is improve debugging support.
Kotlin has a couple
of the constructs
like inline functions that you
don't have in other languages.
And so the new
version of Android
now support debugging
that better.
Then next up, the
Android frameworks,
there's a lot of things
that happen there.
The big thing is that we
added API annotations.
So that's not complete yet.
But any new API, we now have
nullness and default parameter,
have default value
annotations, so you
can use those from Kotlin.
And we're working
through the existing API
to annotate that as well.
Then we added these
Kotlin extension APIs.
So these are extra
libraries that you
include in your
projects that provide
extra APIs through
extension methods that
make your Kotlin
code more idiomatic.
Then we add coroutine
support for a whole bunch
of the Jetpack libraries.
[APPLAUSE]
So this allows you to
write asynchronous code
in a more procedural way.
And of course, yesterday we
announced Jetpack Compose,
which is all Kotlin.
So let's take a
look at the demo.
OK, so if I build
a small app here,
it downloads a
list of shows that
are available from a
server using retrofit.
And then it checks against
the local SQL database
if I've watched these
shows using the room APIs.
So here, you see
that I have defined
the API to get the list of
shows in both using RX Java,
as well as using the Kotlin
coding async feature.
And you see that the APIs
are pretty much the same
with like, just a little
different return type.
And the room side--
oh, sorry.
(QUIETLY) Where did my code go?
OK, we'll skip the API.
It's pretty much--
oh, here it is.
Sorry.
So you see the same thing.
Have I watched the show?
RX in Java, it's very similar.
Here is a Flowable.
There is a [INAUDIBLE].
So the API is pretty similar.
Now let's look at
the way you call
that code between RX and Java--
RX and coroutines.
So in RX, we use a lot of
operators to do our show--
do our flow with all
the asynchronous calls.
And these can become
pretty complex.
And you see that this code
is highlighted yellow.
It means that there's
something I'm not
doing with the return type.
So you need to make sure
that when you subscribe,
you deal with the subscription.
Of course, RX brought great
expressibility to Java.
And the inventors of
RX, they were smart.
They knew what
they were building.
But they were limited
by the language.
In Kotlin, we now
have coroutines
and we can actually
do this much nicer.
So here is the same
code using coroutines.
We first get the list of
shows from the server,
and then we call
this a wait function.
And the ID tells
you, hey, there's
something asynchronous
going on here.
Then we can use
regular for loops.
And it [INAUDIBLE]
over the return shows.
And then we make
our asynchronous
call to see if I have watched
the show in the local database.
And then we continue from there.
And then here, you see
this launch call, which
will tell you,
hey, make this call
to make sure that we notify
that the data set has changed
on the UI thread.
And so the nice thing here is
that it looks more procedural.
And when I do my debugging--
I have to launch now--
And that's not
working, of course.
Oh!
There we go.
It's already running.
So you see that I
can actually look
at variables from
the whole method,
not just from the
specific operator.
And so it makes your
life much easier
when you're debugging
your asynchronous code.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
So next, Android Tooling.
We have done a lot of
stuff in Android Studio
to make sure that Kotlin
is supported well.
The first thing we
did is we made sure
that the Kotlin plugin
is part of Android Studio
so that we can test it
well before we release it.
And we also worked
closely with JetBrains.
Anytime they update
the Kotlin plugin,
we test it before they
go public to make sure
that Android Studio and
Kotlin work well together.
Next, we added Android
specific refactoring support.
There's a lot of
actions in the IDE
that are Android
specific refactorings.
And we're working
on adding support
for all of those in Kotlin.
On the Lint side,
Lint has pretty much
completely rewritten.
It used to write [INAUDIBLE]
checks for Java language.
Now it uses this
thing called UAST,
which allows you to write
the same Lint check once.
And then it can analyze
both Kotlin and Java code.
We added product
templates so that when
you're creating a new
fragment or a new activity,
you have Kotlin code
right in the start.
You don't have to convert that.
Now on the compiler
side, our new Shrinker R8
has a lot of
Kotlin-specific optimization
in it, so that you get
the benefit of making
your code as small as possible.
And of course, the IDE has
now support for the Jetpack
composed framework.
On documentation
and sample site,
if you look at the
developer.android.com,
all API references now have
both Kotlin and Java syntax
available.
There is a Kotlin-specific
documentation portal
which will tell you how to get
started on Kotlin, how to use
caller routines, et cetera.
You also see that a lot of
the samples and snippets
now have Kotlin available.
That's both on the sides,
on our GitHub samples.
As well as if look on
Google I/O this year,
you'll see that most of the
presentations from Androids
do their samples in Kotlin.
There's a couple of apps
you can take a look as well.
The Google I/O app, as well as
this new Android Sunflower app
have been built up from
the ground up using Kotlin.
We often get asked
hey, it's great
that you guys are
recommending Kotlin.
But are you using it yourself?
And of course, that's
a very fair question.
And now at Google, we have a
lot of in-house developer tools.
And so it took us some time to
add Kotlin support to those.
We started out with
internal apps for Googlers.
For instance, there
is an internal app
that shows you maps
and office locations.
And so we learned
a lot from that.
And then since then,
we have actually
started using Kotlin in some
of the public Google Apps.
And so here are some
of the apps that
are shipping Kotlin code
on your phones today.
And you can expect
many more to follow.
Talking about adopting
Kotlin, if you
look at the whole
ecosystem, we've
seen that in active
development--
and active development
is apps that
have had an upload to the Play
store in the last six months,
we see that 16% of the
apps are now using Kotlin.
And keep in mind, an
app can be up developed
just because there's one
bug fix or one asset change.
So 16% is pretty impressive.
That's five times
growth since last I/O.
And if you look at
the top thousand apps,
that's actually
already a lot bigger.
44% of the apps there
we see using Kotlin.
So that brings us
to Kotlin first.
We announced that yesterday.
And so I wanted to give you a
bit more overview of why we did
it and what it's going to mean.
So why would we
announce Kotlin first?
We see strong adoption
of people using Kotlin.
And we see a big
excitement in the community
when people start using Kotlin.
In fact, when people
are asked in our surveys
on how much happier
they're using Kotlin,
they actually score
25% higher than people
who are not using Kotlin.
Many apps across the
industry and inside Google
are now using Kotlin.
We've reached out to
many of our customers,
including our Customer
Advisory Board.
And like, keep focus on
an investment in Kotlin.
So what does that mean?
Of course, we're going to keep
supporting the Java programming
language in many aspects.
Platform, Android
Studio Support, Lint,
like Docs, AndroidX,
that's not going away.
But if you look at
some other efforts
like our online training,
samples, we'll first do Kotlin,
and then Java foreign
language will be best effort.
And then of course,
there are some features
like the multiplatform
projects and Jetpack Compose
that are only going to
be offered in Kotlin.
Now of course, the next question
that we hear from people is,
well, does that mean
I should switch?
Please don't take
Kotlin first as I
need to go take all my Java
code and rewrite it in Kotlin.
That's not what
we want you to do.
Look at Android Studio.
That is many, many hundred
thousand lines of code.
Right now, we're about 10%
Kotlin of the Android Studio
specific code.
And so what we do is we
only take new functionality,
write that in Kotlin.
And it is possible
because Kotlin
has great interoperability
with Java.
You can write a
single class in Kotlin
and keep the rest in Java.
Or have 99% of your
code in Kotlin,
and have only some
leftovers in Java.
Of course, it matters
what is your current state
of your project and team.
If you're one week away
from shipping your release,
that's probably not the best
time to switch to Kotlin.
But if you're starting
a new development cycle,
and you're like, hey, I could
probably take on Kotlin.
And of course, it depends
on your team as well.
Are they interested in Kotlin?
Do they feel secure
taking this on?
We have also found
that a lot of people
actually use mentioning
Kotlin in their recruitment
that they can get a
lot more candidates.
So things to consider--
of course, on the
technical side,
there's also
trade-offs to consider.
Kotlin brings great features,
a lot more productivity,
and satisfaction.
But you have to think
about the learning curve.
It takes time for
people to learn
to write idiomatic Kotlin.
We see that most people
who start writing Kotlin
the first week, they're
really writing Java in Kotlin.
And it takes them
three to six months
to really start writing
idiomatic Kotlin.
That's fine.
I mean, you still get all
the benefits of Kotlin
warning you about
nullness, et cetera.
Then there's the build speed.
Kotlin is slower than
the Java compiler.
It's doing more work for you.
And it's a younger compiler.
We are working hard
on making it faster.
And of course, keep in
mind, yes, it's slower,
but you have to do fewer
builds because your app will
most likely be correcter.
And there is also a APK size.
The app uses standard library,
and it takes some space.
But things like R8 can
help you reduce that.
There's a whole bunch of ongoing
Kotlin work going on at Google.
Of course, Jetpack Compose
is the biggest thing there.
We always keep adding new
KDX APIs all the time.
And then on the compiler side,
we're doing a lot of work
to make it faster.
And like with Kotlin
10330, we added
incrementation processors.
And there's much more to come.
You'll see more improved tooling
and more docs and samples
using Kotlin.
If you're interested
in using Kotlin,
but you're not sure
where to start,
we're announcing
Kotlin Everywhere,
which is a set of trainings
hosted by both Google
and JetBrains.
And it's happening
between now and KotlinConf
at December at the
end of the year.
If you're interested
in that, either
participating or helping
hosting it, go to this link
and sign up.
So with our new
Kotlin first roadmap,
the investments in
Kotlin for Android
is only going to become larger.
I'd like to invite all of you
who haven't tried Kotlin yet
or haven't recently used it,
to try it in your app today.
I hope you'll have a similar
experience like me with Kotlin.
You will be more predictive
and have more fun coding.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]